Speaker 1: Donald Trump is also now admitting
he's going to try to cheat in 2024. Mike Pillow
found out about this and is not in agreement with
Donald Trump. This is super, super interesting.
Donald trump put out a statement. I missed
this originally, but this is just bonkers
stuff. Trump put out a statement saying we
need to beat Democrats in 2024. And of course
the Democrats cheat. It's like, no, no, no, you
tried to steal the election, but put that aside.
He insists Democrats cheat. We need. Trump says
to start ballot harvesting just like they do. We
need to do the ballot harvesting now. Mike Pillow
has been slamming ballot harvesting, alleging that
Democrats do it. And I'll explain what it is in a
moment. For two years now, so Pillow's furious. So
let's listen to what Trump had to say. First.
Speaker 3: The radical left Democrats have
used ballot harvesting to cancel out your
vote and walk away with elections that they
never should have won. They cheat and they
cheat like nobody's ever cheated before.
Many states have banned ballot harvesting to
keep our elections honest and fair. But in the
states where ballot harvesting is still legal,
we have no choice but to beat the Democrats
at their own game. It's very simple. Either we
start ballot harvesting or you can say goodbye
to our country. You lose wave goodbye because
Democrats would win every single election. We
have to get smart. And that's why our campaign
will fight back and start harvesting ballots.
While states where the left has been cheating.
Speaker 1: The scourge of ballot harvesting,
which they will now participate in.
Speaker 3: The system and hurting our country.
But our harvested ballots will only come from
legal registered voters who are American citizen.
Speaker 1: Are you going to harvest ballots
but from legal voters, whereas Democrats were
harvesting ballots from illegal voters?
Speaker 3: With your help, we will master
the Democrats game of ballot harvesting and we
will win back the White House from Joe Biden and
the people that are destroying our country. Okay.
Speaker 1: So ballot harvesting means you collect
and submit completed ballots on behalf of voters.
So the idea is there's someone who says, I will
collect the ballots, you fill your ballot out,
I will go and collect it. And it's a technique
used to increase voter turnout, especially when
there are people who have a tough time getting
to polling stations, either because they live
very rurally and don't have a car or they have a
physical limitation or whatever the reason may be.
In general, the term ballot harvesting means, Oh,
I will go and collect ballots. Now, the legality
varies from state to state and jurisdiction
to serve this jurisdiction. In some places it's
legal and regulated. In some places it's illegal.
Some states say you can do it, but you can only
do it for family members and caregivers. You
can't just have the person on your block who says,
I'll collect everyone's ballots and drop them off,
or whatever the case may be. It's become a very
hot topic in the U.S. recently because the right
is arguing the left harvests ballots, but they
do it with coercion. They encourage voter fraud.
They get a bunch of illegal voters to fill out
ballots and then they collect them. There's no
evidence of any of this stuff, but it's what the
story they've been telling. So Trump saying we
should do it puts Mike Pillow in sort of a strange
position. And Mike Pillow says, I spoke to Trump
about this. He's never going to say it again.
Speaker 4: There's voter fraud. But also recently
he's been saying, let's beat the left at their own
game, at least until we get into office so that.
Speaker 5: No, no, no, no, don't even go there.
I've talked to him about them. We are not going
to do what they're doing. We're not going to
ballot harvest. We we and you will not hear
him saying that this is we've worked two years to
get him to get same day voting paper ballots here.
Speaker 1: He's like, I've been I've been killing
myself. I spent 35 million fighting against ballot
harvesting and now Trump's going to do it.
Speaker 5: On another machine. And if you
say that we want to do what they
do, ballot, harvest and do this,
the Republicans would just make it legal
to do what's illegal in a lot of states,
and it's over. We lose our country. So that
narrative, you will not hear him saying
that anymore. I know. I don't even want to.
Speaker 1: Yeah. Pillow didn't even really
want to talk about it. So pillow says No, no,
no, no, no, no, no. I heard about that. I went
to Trump. We're not going to be talking about that
anymore. We can't really do it. So this is this is
obviously fascinating. And it doesn't seem totally
clear to me whether Donald Trump understands.
The issue is less about, obviously any kind of
ballot collection, regardless of the state or
jurisdiction. You can only collect legal ballots
if you somehow again imagine the scenarios they
dream up. If you somehow find 10,000 blank
ballots and bring them to people who aren't
registered to vote, I guess you have to find find
10,000 undocumented immigrants who, of course,
they're going to live all over the place and
you're going to drive around distributing ballots
to undocumented immigrants and then picking them
up. Obviously, that's illegal because the voters
aren't legal registered voters. The collection
is what's at issue. In some places, anyone can
collect ballots for others. In other places,
it's limited to family or caregivers. There are
different rules in different places. In Trump's
mind, he's just like, Well, Democrats do ballot
harvesting, but with illegal ballots. Whereas
we're going to do it with only legal citizens, but
we're going to help them. He doesn't even actually
understand the controversy over ballot harvesting,
which isn't surprising because increasingly
he doesn't really understand anything.